[Music]
as of this recording almost a million of
you watched my chat with jordan peterson
and ben shapiro last week on youtube and
a couple hundred thousand more of you
have listened to the audio podcast while
the mainstream media continues to
spoon-feed the masses soundbite
clickbait we're here doing some real
proof of concept work to prove that you
guys are a lot smarter than they think
while mainstream media focuses on trumps
diet coke habit we're here talking about
the Marxist roots of post-modernism and
the secular and religious arguments over
where rights come from i received a
bunch of emails from you guys after the
livestream saying that jordan often says
things that go over your head but you
actually go ahead and pause the video
and do some research for yourself I'll
be totally honest with you sometimes he
says things that fly by me as well and
while I usually try to pause him to
clarify obviously I can't always do that
in the midst of a conversation while
you're learning through these
conversations know that I'm learning
right next to you
after the Petersons Shapiro live stream
Jordan got in a well-deserved nap and
then spoke to a sold-out crowd of 2,000
people at the Orpheum Theatre here in LA
Jordan was nice enough to let me
introduce him as a special surprise
guest to the audience and I got to tell
you it was truly the best reception I've
ever received on stage I did a couple
minutes to stand up cracking jokes about
lobsters and the importance of cleaning
your room but there was something beyond
just the laughs that I could feel on the
stage the room felt lit with intellect
and curiosity 2,000 strangers coming
together to hear a middle-aged
psychology professor talk about how
fixing yourself is the only way to fix
the world
this simply wouldn't have happened even
two years ago because so many of you who
dare think differently were silenced by
false cries of racism and bigotry people
like Jordan and Ben are using their
intellect to say what they believe and
that in turn is showing millions of
people out there that they can do the
exact same thing whether you like or
hate Trump this idea revolution is
directly related to his election
everything is up in the air right now
from our political institutions to our
educational institutions to our media
instead
toons as Eric Weinstein and I discussed
a few months back perhaps some of us
would have preferred less upheaval to
get us to address the problems with
these institutions but perhaps that more
selective tactful upheaval actually
never happens as I said to Eric he
wanted a panther in a china shop but all
that was available was the bull as the
Rolling Stones taught us you can't
always get what you want but you get
what you need as most of you probably
have already seen we followed up our
chat with Peterson and Shapiro with the
brothers weinstein Eric and Brett it was
their first public appearance together
ever and I have to say that my brain is
still in recovery mode from taking in so
many high-level important ideas if the
dial of ideas was turned too low for the
last few years it's quickly moving into
the hot position the dial is moving
because the conversations were having
here are finally starting to leak out
into the rest of the world
that's why thousands of you are showing
up at Jordan Peterson events and at live
Sam Harris podcasts and by the way Sam
and Jordan disagree on pretty much
everything especially the most
fundamental existential questions that
exist yet we're all on the same side
because the only real enemy is the
authoritarians who want to control us so
that they can have a silenced once you
realize that you'll suddenly find
yourself with many more allies and many
less enemies so it probably goes without
saying that I'm feeling incredibly
positive about the direction things are
heading and I hope that you are too this
month we're gonna continue having real
conversations with people who are truly
affecting the world with their thoughts
and their actions we've got a five-time
bank robber who became a Georgetown Law
professor we've got a former head of
FEMA and we've got a nuclear power
expert running for governor of
California also I'm thrilled to share
with you that we're doing five shows in
five days with five experts on five
different presidents of the United
States to celebrate presidents week from
some founders like Jefferson Adams and
Madison to JFK and Lincoln the stories
of our past are as relevant as ever as
we fight for the liberty of today oh and
yes we'll be doing plenty more of the
three-person sit downs as well who do
you want sitting down across from each
other let us know in the comments right
down below after all there's an idea
revolution happening right now and it
may not be televised
but it's definitely
to be streamed
[Music]
you